avec arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
nous sommes également avec frédéric
sinclair éditorialiste ancien conseiller
politique de dominique de villepin
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors un groupe un dissident à
nouveau à la république en marche en
pleine crise sanitaire est ce que cela
vous surprend-il arnaud benedetti et
volodia écoutez c'est finalement toute
l'ambiguïté de la démarche des malades
emmanuel macron depuis le début emmanuel
macron est partis du centre gauche
ça a été d'ailleurs son socle à la fois
et idéologique électorale et sa pratique
du pouvoir depuis qu'il a accédé à
l'elysée l'a progressivement et
constamment déportés vers le centre
droit et donc il est naturel que dans
une période qui est une période
difficile après trois ans le mandat avec
des événements sociaux comme les gilet
jaune qui ont profondément bousculé
l'exécutif qu'une partie de son aile
gauche se pose des questions sur la
ligne politique du président de la
république alors évidemment ça va
fragiliser mathématiquement si ce groupe
se crée la majorité parlementaire qui
deviendrait dépendante à la fois du bon
vouloir de ce groupe mais également du
bon vouloir du modem qui dispose d'à peu
près d'une cinquantaine de
parlementaires
frédéric saint clair vous vous êtes
surpris par ce projet je j'ai consacré
en 2019
mon premier édito de l'année janvier
2019 en pleine crise des gilet jaune
à ce sujet je pensais qu'en 2019 sarris
produire et donc j'avais pronostiqué une
fracturation de l'électorat macro nist
auquel je ne trouvais déjà aucune unité
je trouve que manuel macron a plutôt
bien résisté à la crise des gilet jaune
et c'est la crise du coc vide qui
finalement fracture ce socle qui est
composite arnaud bennet hilale a rappelé
emmanuel macron a glissé lentement de la
gauche vers la droite et il n'a jamais
fait mystère de sa volonté d'aggloméré
différents temps de la société politique
et civile
ce qui pose évidemment des problèmes en
matière de cohésion et ses problèmes
allaient de toute façon se révéler pour
pour modérer quand même ce départ
ces gens là ont besoin d'exister ils ont
un agenda politique propre et s'ils
s'inscrivent dans une opposition bête et
méchante
ils n'existeront plus et peuvent
provoquer une crise politique beaucoup
plus grave qui peut conduire à une
dissolution
donc c'est pas leur intérêt parce qu'ils
pourraient perdre leur siège donc il
faut pas non plus sûr interpréter cette
fracture en sur un terreau pas mais il
n'empêche on se souvient tous des
frondeurs qui ont causé beaucoup de tort
aux prédécesseurs d'emmanuel macro à
françois hollande arnaud benedetti le
moment est tout de même un graphe pour
un emmanuel macron déjà fragilisés ont
visé par la crise et gilet jaune
évidemment et maintenant par cette crise
du corps des virus
oui parce que c'est un moment compliqué
au monde à laisse-t-on il va falloir qui
le gère les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire le pays quand d'autres pays
européens va être confronté en déchets à
une crise économique et sociale
vraisemblablement sans précédent donc
gérer cette crise avec une majorité qui
est soudainement prise d'un certain
nombre de problèmes de conscience c'est
bien évidemment une équation qui est
beaucoup plus difficile donc emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui
se retrouve confronté aux limites de
l'exercice
si vous voulez la démarche de
rassemblement qui était la sienne est
une démarche de rassemblement qu'il a
construite autour d'un certain nombre
d'idées qui finalement constitué le plus
petit dénominateur commun pour faire
tenir ensemble des gens venant
d'horizons différents le rassemblement
c'est une autre quelques chose de
complexe lorsque et giscard d'estaing a
essayé dans les années 70 lui aussi de
lancer sa fameuse formule de deux
français sur trois il se repose et
néanmoins sur un groupe parlementaire
qui restait malgré tout à socle solide
malgré un allié gaulliste qui dureront
tout le monde a en tout cas la seconde
partie du mandat lui a causé bien des
difficultés lorsque le général de gaulle
rassembler il avait une majorité
parlementaire qui était extrêmement
solide et puis il y avait surtout des
militants qui étaient des militants
chevronnés des parlementaires qui
étaient chevronnés
là en l'occurrence manifestement on est
quand même aussi avec un groupe
parlementaire dont il ne faut jamais
oublier qu'il n'a pas le degré de
professionnalisation et
vraisemblablement de conscience
militante que les groupes parlementaires
d'autres président de la république
avait on leur tend alors le nom c'est
démocratie écologie solidarité les mots
ont un sens évidemment c'est pas vous je
vais l'apprendre frédéric saint clair ça
veut dire quoi qui manquait pour ses
députés un peu de démocratie un peu
d'écologie un peu de solidarité
oui vivement il manquait de la gauche
finit manquait un emmanuel macron avec
une main gauche il avait de main droite
donc il ya un vrai problème de
droitisation du président de du point de
vue de sa majorité
pas du point de vue de son électorat et
c'est là que se noue toute la
problématique des manuels macron pour
les mois à venir c'est que le risque de
fracturation majeur au niveau de la glas
de sa majorité donc à l'assemblée pour
le vote des lois se situe sur sa gauche
et son électorat se situe sur sa droite
et donc soit il continue de satisfaire
son électorat avec une communication et
jeudi d une communication
de plus en plus droitière qui lui montre
qu'il a bien compris les problématiques
liées à la relance économique à
l'accumulation de richesses à la
protection des frontières à la
souveraineté où vous avez vu notamment
le terme
dans l'interview du financial times
exploser littéralement répéter un nombre
de fois incalculable donc là il
il ouvre une porte très très large sur
tout c'est ce nouvel électorat potentiel
souverainistes dont une large partie est
à droite donc il se met directement en
concurrence avec marine le pen
et puis pour comme pour l'embêter et
bien c'est sur sa gauche que ça se
fracture à l'assemblée il va falloir les
voter ces lois et à ce moment là il va
falloir rallier le côté gauche si
emmanuel macron veut faire plaisir à ce
groupe frondeur il risque de déplaire à
son électorat il est vraiment coincé
j'allais dire entre deux feux arnaud
benedetti pourtant emmanuel macron à
nous l'a promis il faut se réinventer en
parlant de 7 après crise du comique 19
et moi le premier at il dit ça veut dire
qu'il va plutôt basculer sur sa gauche
emmanuel macron à l'avenir difficile de
dire c'est qu'il est sur une ligne de
crête pianais confortable aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que l'électorat
d'emmanuel macron s'est droitisée
regardez les résultats des dernières
élections européennes et qu'on coup vous
vous observez les scores obtenus par la
liste conduite par madame l'oiseau ce
sont des scores qui sont importants dans
des zones qui sociologiquement et
territorialement sont plutôt à droite
voire en tout cas au centre droit donc
il y à un exercice qui est extrêmement
compliquée où on voit un emmanuel macron
qui historiquement quand même par du
centre gauche il faut jamais oublier
quand même qu'il a été secrétaire
général ministre le secrétaire général
adjoint de l'elysée ministre de françois
hollande et qui progressivement à vue
s'agréger vers sa marque électorale tout
une sociologie électorale est plutôt
disons de centre-droit donc c'est très
difficile
lui d'arbitrer entre eux finalement ces
parlementaires qui viennent de la gauche
et cette nouvelle sociologie électorale
qui vient plutôt de la droite et il va
de soi que ayant quand même grillé une
partie de ces vaisseaux à gauche depuis
trois ans ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour lui de reconquérir un
électorat qui aujourd'hui
vraisemblablement ne lui fait pas
confiance parce qu'ils considèrent qu'il
mène une plutôt que politique que la
politique pour laquelle éventuellement
il a été élu et surtout parce que
aujourd'hui il est lui même d'une
certaine façon aussi concurrencer sur sa
droite sur un certain nombre de
thématiques qui l'a remis au goût du
jour qui sont les thématiques de
souveraineté mais qu'il ne peut pas
véritablement présenter parce que
d'autres forces politiques depuis
maintenant six ans autant on prêt en
plus c'était m un dernier thème que je
voulais être regardés avec vous
messieurs et le premier ministre dans
tout ça on a longuement commenté les
tensions les pseudos tension en tout cas
avec emmanuel macron qui ont été
démenties par ce dernier les rumeurs de
changement ces derniers jours et les
votre point de vue sur ce point frédéric
saint clair vous pensez que edouard
philippe ne va pas finir ce quinquennat
alors ne va pas je ne peux pas vous le
dire j'ai pas ma boule de cristal avec
moi ce soir mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que si emmanuel macron veut
réellement se détacher de cette pénible
crise du coc vide qui va
psychologiquement un impact et la
mentalité des français et qui va se
traduire comme l'a dit arnaud benedetti
en une crise sociale et économique très
rapidement et surtout en une crise
politique majeure
on est au tout début d'une profonde
crise politique type gilet jaune
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je vois
c'est à dire quelque chose qui va
vraiment secoué l'opinion va ya voir
s'en rend pas encore compte maintenant
mais un profond sentiment de rejet c'est
en train de monter de plus en plus dans
l'opinion ce qui veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire que si emmanuel macron
veut anticiper un après faut absolument
se séparer se couper de la base de
l'avant en partie donc ça veut dire
remodelé en gardant les figures qui sont
intéressantes et qui s'en sont bien
sortis pendant cette crise
du coup vide et on écartant un certain
nombre d'autres figures et notamment la
principale edouard philippe donc si
vraiment emmanuel macron veut anticiper
2022 dans les meilleures conditions il
va falloir qu'il doit philips on highway
and obesity est ce que vous partagez le
diagnostic l'analyse de frédéric cinq
heures parce qu'enfin en attendant
edouard philippe peuvent s'en sort un
peu mieux en termes de cote de confiance
que le président lui même
et oui c'est bien toute la difficulté et
la complexité de la faire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on comprend que le manque
de stabilité
et si ce n'est de cette majorité mais en
tout cas de cet exécutif pour une partie
de l'opinion publique c'est edouard
philippe et ce n'est plus le président
de et ce n'est plus le président de la
république
donc at-il intérêt de se séparer aussi
rapidement du premier ministre qui plus
tôt a fait le job dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles
c'est une question qui se pose à lui il
trouvera bien évidemment une solution de
substitution mais la vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui d'aimer d'emmanuel macro un
lit double c'est qu' il est temps
défiance en tout cas l'opinion publique
une grande partie de l'opinion publique
une majorité l'opinion publique et en
défiance vis-à-vis de lui et il a
aujourd'hui dix ont une ligne de
défiance à l'intérieur même de sa
majorité
donc il va falloir qu'ils se battent sur
deux fronts à la fois le front de
l'opinion et le front du parlement et
vous savez tous les généraux qui se sont
battus sur deux fronts en règle générale
ont perdu
c'est donc un exercice particulièrement
périlleux aujourd'hui auxquels il est
confronté
merci à tous les deux arnaud benedettini
frédéric saint clair d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france